[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the last criminal of Scotland
did you notice that it looked like
someone put that dirt in the shovel for
him
he's never used a [__] shovel in his
life come on
proved me wrong
give me the tape of where this guy has
ever ever used a shovel and I'll believe
it
it looks like someone put the dirt in
the shovel and handed it to him doesn't
it looks like it to me like everything
else he's faking it [__] faking it
but I do like the outfit though trump it
really is fitting that's how you're
gonna look
after all your legal woes have wind down
like you're literally
you're no longer going to be wearing the
stupid Trump drag you'll be wearing an
outfit makes you look like the last
criminal of Scotland and this this
morning the E Gene Carol rape and
defamation trial continue
as it doesn't look like that's going to
go well for Donald Trump as they prepare
for appeals again they tried to
have a strongly worded letter to get a
menstrual and didn't succeed there is a
video going around speaking of trump not
succeeding and being a [__] loser
there is a video going around of
Taylor Swift and I believe this was in
2019 2012 I I'm not sure exactly the
year and it was right before the 2020
election where Taylor Swift and her
family
um were sitting around talking about how
she just couldn't stay quiet anymore
she's not gonna stay quiet she's not
going to be polite about the politics
anymore she's going to speak out
um and what what really is uh stunning
in the clip is that
the people who are famous for other
things than politics or their political
opinions
are have to measure how they how they
tell their story and say their opinions
is the first stunning thing
because she says in the clip and I'm
gonna show it later
right
in the clip she says that um she was not
in a spot and it seemed like maybe her
mental health or or her situation it
just wasn't going well for her in 2016
that she wasn't able to to speak out
against Trump specifically against Trump
and she says no I'm I'm going to do it I
don't I don't give a [__]
and the first reaction of her father now
listen to me listen to me when I tell
you this her first reaction from her
father is that they will shoot you
that is his reaction he says I'm the one
who had to order the bulletproof cars
think about that for a second
Taylor Swift is one of the most famous
people in the entire [__] world I
don't know I don't know if you you watch
but her supporting or not supporting or
a candidate or being against Trump
didn't affect
Taylor Swift's popularity
she went to Arizona which if you talk to
Kerry Lake it's a red state
she went to Arizona to Phoenix Arizona
and there were more people at her
[__] concert than than we're at the
Super Bowl
it didn't affect her economically and
and really in the clip she doesn't give
two [__] shits
it seems to me about rather she's gonna
lose a couple bucks or two she doesn't
give a [__] at that point
but her dad's number one first thought
in his brain are they are going to kill
you with a gun
think about that for a second
think about the time that we're in with
these [__] Nazis
now I get [__] all the time oh you're
you're going a little far you're saying
I mean come on Tony Jesus Christ
I showed you yesterday
Nazis who are Republicans who went and
dressed up in costume to protest a
costume show in Columbus Ohio and then I
showed you the leader of that group
talking Republican talking points on
women's health care
in Oklahoma
they're full on gonna get rid of
education and libraries and do full-on
theocracy in Oklahoma
I I showed you a clip the other day of a
goddamn Pastor standing on stage saying
yes God should be the laws and we should
get to dictate them Christianity is the
only religion and it should be the law
the state superintendent wants
wants to ban and burn books baby
they're [__] Nazis there's another
clip oh boy in the great state of
Florida because we can't forget the
Floridian fascist out there
of a lawmaker
a duly elected lawmaker standing on the
floor
in Florida
of their house
saying out loud
that Republicans hate gay people I'm not
[__] you this is real
I'm telling you
and I I know I I've been loud and
screaming for two years into this
microphone but I'm dead serious about it
they're coming for your [__]
and yes they're gonna try to start in
Florida and Texas and Oklahoma and
Tennessee that's where it starts
but they're going to try to take your
government rather it's your school board
whether it's your County Commission
whether it's your State Legislature
your your state executive branch
they're gonna try to take your U.S
Congress seats they're going to try to
take your Senate seats and and and
your presidential seat
all in the name of fascism and theocracy
we need to Ring the Alarm Bells because
I know that the majority of my audience
gets this
I know you get this
it's not hard to see when I show it to
you
it's not hard
and yes we should mock it like we mocked
the Nazis yesterday because it is kind
of pathetic and I I do have to say that
Hitler would be completely [__]
disappointed in these nincompoop Nazis
that we have here in America today
because they are nincompoops but
they are still Nazis
and I'm gonna keep saying it I don't
give a [__] if they get mad at me if
they're upset it's it's at them problems
stop being a [__] fascist
stop wanting to legislate people out of
[__] existence stop telling people
who the [__] they can and cannot love
and who the [__] they can and cannot
want to be with or hang around with or
not be around
and stop telling parents what the [__]
you're gonna teach them in their schools
hang in the Ten Commandments in all the
classrooms in Texas
well by God I think I think there's
probably a Satan is somewhere in Texas
that should request the state to hang
their satanic plaque in every [__]
classroom I'm sure there is one out
there that is com needs their satanic
plaque
for the government to Define their
religion in every classroom
[__] them it's it's enough of this
garbage it's enough of standing back and
waiting for these idiots
to pass laws
to oppress the majority ideology it is
enough of this [__] and take away
people's [__] Liberty
and if people in this country knew what
the [__] they were doing
they wouldn't stand for this [__] there
wouldn't even be space for these
[__] to exist trust me
but they're they're they're they're too
enamored by their thirst traps on
Instagram
by their their sports ball
on ESPN
and yeah it's hard because there's a lot
of distraction
and these people get to hear no evil see
no evil speak no evil but we have to
make them hear us
we have to be loud
we have to show them that hey your your
way of life is at risk
do you think the majority of this
country wants to wants to be told what
religion and what God and where they can
and cannot worship or how they can
worship or they have to worship you
think the majority get the [__] out of
here if you think that's the majority of
the ideology of this country you are a
dumb some [__] if you think that's the
majority you are not you are not living
in reality
you are in a [__] fascist bubble
trust me
even people who who [__] identify as
Christian don't even go to church
anymore because of because of how fast
she it is
this is not what Jesus would do
speaking of that Matt Walsh I got
exclusive footage by the way of Matt
Walsh today I've got exclusive footage
it's uncovered of Matt Walsh appearing
at the Met Gala that's right I have it
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
he showed up in a costume yeah I mean it
wasn't very good costume but I got the
footage don't go anywhere stick around
I'm going to show you this but Matt
Walsh also that vile piece of human
trash
decides to to tweet out a comment to a
question that was that was leveled to
him on his show and I I it looks like
it's from some streaming service to me
I'm not sure if it's Instagram or if
it's if it's uh Facebook or if I'm not
really sure
but he tweeted out his comment and oh my
god oh man let me tell you
Jesus Jesus hates by the way
uh is his position Jesus hates
folks
You Gotta Get Loud and and and frankly
we all have to be loud and I always say
that I only have one microphone and you
have thousands you have you are
thousands of voices
so let's turn it into tens of thousands
let's turn it into a hundreds of
thousands
share this episode share this show share
other independent shows that speak out
against these [__] that don't
play this game like the media does like
CNN
is gonna have a [__] traitor they're
gonna hold a town hall for the guy who
tried to overthrow our [__]
government committed a coup he's he's
charged with 34 felonies a business
fraud convicted of 17 in the state of
New York and they're like yeah we're
gonna have a down home oh man well his
his supporters want to hear his opinion
[__] out of here with that nonsense
turn that [__] off
turn it off
stop watching them stop giving them your
[__] ratings
go watch some people who are [__]
sick and tired of the lies and the
[__]
what you consume what you hear what you
watch matters and how you message and
how you form a narrative around it is
super important to our democracy you are
the government We the People
you are it
the big government isn't some kind of
Shadow deep State thing that we keep
adding on to a [__] concrete building
somewhere it's you
you're it
act like it be it yell scream Get Loud
because the fascist Kryptonite is very
very high volumes
they don't like it it hurts their ears
it's enough of the garbage
it's enough of them being proud
of their dis their discriminatory ways
of trying to box people out of our
society take away people's rights take
away Women's Health Care take away
people's right to love who the [__] they
want to love
be who they want to [__] be what's it
your business huh
stay the [__] out of other people's
lives it's enough of the [__]
telling you if you don't see this white
Christian nationalism
as a threat to our democracy and you
know um
I sent our message in 2024 was going to
be democracy or autocracy I actually
think we're getting to the point where
it's democracy our theocracy like what
do you want you want handmaid's tale is
that what you want
and they think it's a [__] movie I
showed you a clip the other day
this Cuban honor saying yeah it's all a
big movie
it's all being produced it's all a big
movie
you're not gonna win back that
[__]
you're not going to win him back
but the people who aren't paying
attention the people who don't know
what's going on we can win them
we can win them to vote for democracy
and oh by the way oh by the way
um a lot of people have asked me to
speak about this
and uh
it's come to my attention and I've spoke
about it a time or two
but we're gonna we're gonna turn our aim
towards no labels
and I'm gonna show you a clip of Joe
Lieberman if you remember who that
[__] is as if he's [__]
relevant
are you kidding me Joe Lieberman get the
[__] out of here
this is the this is this is gonna be the
[__] face of No Labels come on
give me a break is this are you [__]
serious well we're gonna get serious
about it
here on the Tony Michaels podcast and
I'm gonna Smash It Up with a goddamn
Hammer that's what I'm gonna do I don't
give a [__]
they plan on holding some convention in
2024 good do it
Who you gonna get
what's your candidate
who do you think is gut who do you think
is gonna go to bed at night
and try to get some rest when when they
are responsible
for ending our democracy huh
Who you gonna get
who is it gonna be tell me I want to
find out I want to know who your
candidate is and we'll challenge them
we'll see how we'll see how resilient
they are on an independent ticket
we'll find out
so let's do that
we got Texas Paul here today it's
Tuesday of course we had Texas Paul
it's Taco Tuesday Texas Paul Tuesday
it's just Tuesday in general and I'm
excited I always like Tuesday Tuesday's
like the Friday before hump day right
it's what it is it's what it is you get
hump day and then you got Friday before
hump day which is Tuesday
oh boy
I'm I'm excited about showing you these
uh this uh Taylor Swift
um video I think we're gonna break that
down really well also um in the news uh
the officer who stood back and and tried
to hold back concerned citizens in the
George Floyd murder stood there and
watched
Derek Chauvin murder
George Floyd
as he was like stay back bystanders he's
not really murdering he just kind of
murdering him he's been convicted of
aiding uh manslaughter so good [__] him
and lock him up lock him up lock anyone
else up just like him [__] him uh I I
don't know exactly what the uh
um in Minneapolis with the uh or
Minnesota excuse me what the sentencing
is going to be and I don't even know I
don't think they've actually sentenced
him yet he's just been convicted of
aiding manslaughter
um and it felt like to me the words of
the judge were pretty strong in that
favor
um so there's that been a news as well
we might talk about that today uh let's
see what out what else what else
what else do we get
um yesterday was May Day I forgot to
bring that up a lot of people and think
the Labor Day in this country is the
actual Labor Day and May Day is actually
Labor Day there's just uh reasons why we
don't celebrate may day is Labor Day in
this country Texas Paul might be able to
tell us a little more about that he
might have the history of that uh so
maybe we'll ask him about that let's see
what what else do I have what else do I
have for you today
um I I want to show you the video of
of trump acting like he knows how to use
a shovel oh my God
[Music]
oh man
it's [__] hilarious wow
and of course that the um he's in
Scotland and the outfit he was wearing
was
oh so on trump it wasn't Trump drag but
it's hilarious the other video I got
from you is um from the superintendents
of schools in Oklahoma and I also want
if I have time I want to go back and
show you
um also that preacher that I was showing
you the other day who said yes
Christianity is the only religion and it
should dictate our laws of the land
um so I want to show you that and of
course I do have the exclusive footage
of Matt Walsh arriving at the Met Gala
uh in his um great costume so don't
don't go anywhere we're gonna watch that
um also the other video that I'm going
to show you today
is of this uh Florida GOP Nazi uh Jeff
Holcomb our Holcomb or Holcomb or some
[__] I don't know it's [__] Nazi he's
a [__] Nazi and he says on the floor
of the Florida house that that
Republicans hate homosexuals so that's
what he said he literally he said out
loud that Republicans hate homosexuals
I I don't I don't get to make the
[__] Clips I just [__] show them
to you so I don't know what else to do
here um also I have another another
theatric
theatric and Theocratic
hate preacher as he's called in the clip
um and I'm not sure exactly where this
is from but he is very scared he's very
scared that women drink Dr Pepper and he
thinks if you drink Dr Pepper it might
turn you into a woman or turn you are
gay I'm not really sure I don't know
it's kind of confusing the the right is
extremely excited that Bud Light sales
went down last month
hey hey chuds wait till three months
from now
and we'll talk over the summer over the
summer we'll talk about Bud Light sales
okay
oh these [__] idiots I also want to
show you a clip I've got time from Paris
um France where um protesters set a cop
on fire I'm not [__] you they said a
police officer on fire they know how to
Stage a goddamn demonstration
over there in in Paris France holy [__]
baby
um I've gotta listen there are so many
[__] Clips I've got one of uh James
Comer also talking about Hunter Biden so
we got we got tons to get to so I might
as well get to it early and Texas Paul
is in the green room so I think he's
ready to go so let's do this let's go to
a break when we come back
we're gonna start running through the
[__] that we need to run through so
everyone can see so you can share it
with your family friends and the manga
idiot down the road don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run at Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again here's
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
easy
[Music]
you guys over on Twitter kicking ass
that's right
all the shout outs to the twitchers over
there everybody if you're not following
us on Twitch you're not doing it
correctly I'm telling you you're not
we've we've gotten a lot of people that
have uh actually linked their Amazon
Prime account to our Twitch account
which is so awesome it is one of the
easiest ways and it's very free if you
already have an Amazon Prime account to
give monetary support to the show listen
here's what you do if you have an Amazon
Prime account you link it to a Twitch
account just download both apps on your
phone you can link them together and you
get one free subscription on Twitch
one free subscription on Twitch with
your Amazon Prime account you subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast every month
you have to do it every month you
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
every single month and we get a few
bucks literally here's how it works it's
five bucks or 4.99 what however you want
to shake it out right it's five dollars
Amazon gives twitch five dollars they
take half of it then they take a fee and
we get two dollars and some change but
it is a free way for you to give
monetary support to the show and I
appreciate everyone who has done it
we're gaining more and more subscribers
every single day but I want to tell you
something even if you don't have an
Amazon Prime account you can go over to
Twitch and you can follow us there hell
watch and see what the chat's like over
there there's a chat room going on over
there too
so again
make sure if you have an Amazon Prime
account that you're linking it to your
Twitch account and giving us that one
free subscription every single month you
have to renew it every single month and
make sure you're following us you don't
have to have an Amazon Prime account to
follow us that's free it doesn't cost
you anything so thank you very much for
all the support over on Twitch and if
you're on YouTube like And subscribe
right now share this link
also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify and Google
it's free99 over there you get a five
finger discount on Facebook if you still
have a Facebook account just follow us
at the Tony Michaels and you get your
five finger discount this show is free
two hours every single day free free
free 99.
and do I have a treat for you today for
free as we do every Tuesday Texas Paul
is here Texas Paul how are you my friend
man I am wonderful Tony I am wonderful I
am I have felt this good in ages really
in ages yeah I'm fired up did Trump send
you some Adderall or something I don't
know I'm just
is saying you seem really happy
yesterday that the picture of him
holding the shovel oh my God and the
video is even better I'm going to show
you this video but first thing I'm first
thing I want to do because yesterday I
failed to mention on the show because
there was a lot of [__] going on
um yesterday with Greg Abbott I had to
put him in his place and we had a lot of
video to get to I didn't get to
everything that I wanted to get to but
you know how that goes
um but yesterday was May Day right and a
lot of people don't know this but may
day is Labor Day all around the world
except for here in the United States
because an event that happened way back
when uh in Chicago Market Affair that's
right
um I think there was wasn't there eight
police officers that were killed
um in that I believe uh what no police
officers a lot of police officers were
hurt but I believe a couple of the
rioters were also killed right right
well please
go ahead go ahead uh please tend not to
like it when you throw bombs in their
ranks they tend to get a little riled
you know they did throw bombs at them of
course not as not as sophisticated as a
bomb would be today but speaking of that
I want to show you
um a video from Paris France
um you know that they're trying to
change the retirement age over there and
I want to give people's perspective
they're changing their retirement age I
believe 65 to 69 they're changing it
four years
um they're using parts of their
constitution uh and their Supreme Court
to to Ram this down the people's throat
they do not want it they don't want it
so much that they're setting cops on
fire here's a video of it watch
[Music]
thank you
this is some crazy [__] Texas ball and
again uh I I wish I wish we could get as
much just just like 20 of that sort of
outrage about the fascism here as they
are about four years raising the
retirement year age four years now in in
France the trash is piling up everywhere
now people are are walking off the job
uh I mean they're in full-on National
protest uh there in France because uh
the government's going to tell them that
they can't retire uh four years later
than than what they have been before and
Tony I thought I thought it was two
years I thought they were raising it
from 62 to 64. and I you know again I
I'm not abreast to the the the age and
the difference that they're wanting but
I do know that it's is that that's why
everybody's having such a fit about it
because most people have retirement ages
around 65 right like we do where it
starts here at 65.
um they're they're raising theirs from
62 to 64. so their politicians thought
oh we're good we're still less than
everybody else oh hell no do not mess
with the French people and their
benefits man they they do not take that
[__] it sounds like the audience is
confirming this that it's 62 to 64.
they're all saying it's two years so
it's even less than I was saying right I
mean it's even less than I would sing
it's 24 months two years uh is the
difference so yeah everyone's saying two
years but here's here's the thing here's
the thing is that if we could just get
just a hint I'm not talking about
setting cops on fire I mean yet yet
but but we're getting into a situation
in this country where people need to
start having outrage and and and there
it's a little different than here
but the Republicans this week are trying
to Ram through 22 cut to VA benefits how
in the [__] this country isn't in an
uproar over this and how the Republicans
are able to get away with it and this
morning the mainstream media is pimping
oh well the Republicans brought
something to the table so why aren't the
Senate Democrats bringing something to
the table and this is par on course for
the mainstream media to play right into
the hands of the right wing democracy
that is the real America First Nazi
party the Republicans especially in the
house and the extremists in the Senate
is that they just placate to this idea
that the American people have to put up
with tying the debt ceiling which is
appropriated funds from the past that we
must pay it's already been appropriated
by Republicans by with their consent
that we have to tie it somehow to the
Future budget [__] you that is not
something we have to do and if the
country got pissed off uh about that as
much as
um people in France are pissed off about
two years changing retirement age I
would bet that Republicans would pass to
raise the debt ceiling limit tomorrow
that's what they would do and Senate
would pass it the president would sign
it but people aren't [__] paying
attention right or am I wrong maybe
they're just they like NBA basketball
semifinals way too much
no you're absolutely right we have no
media left in this country no no no
Mains that anything that that's
mainstream CNN is a [__] joke pardon
my language I'm sorry uh it is a joke
um yeah you're on this [__] you know
people don't realize and veterans are
starting to wake up because a lot of
these veteran groups are losing it you
know like vote vets and a lot of these
other veteran groups are just completely
losing it over these cuts and the
Republicans are trying to run this
boondoggle it's such a load of [__] Tony
they're trying to say well we didn't
specifically enumerate cuts to Veterans
Affairs we didn't specifically enumerate
cuts to the FDA and the USDA and
everything else the discretionary
spending pays for so they're saying whoa
because it doesn't say it we didn't do
it that's as stupid as saying hey Tony
I'm going to cut your pay 20 and you say
well hey man I got to buy groceries pay
rent and I say well I didn't cut your
money to pay rent I didn't cut your
money to pay groceries
it's not I didn't write this show me
where it's written down that I cut your
money to pay rent and groceries it's
that freaking stupid Tony it's it and
politics girl did an amazing video I
pimped this thing all the time she did
an amazing video talking about the debt
ceiling and just how freaking useless it
is you know back when it took two weeks
to a month
for somebody to get from
bum [__] Egypt to Washington DC riding a
damn horse or a train or whatever that's
when the debt ceiling made sense
it was a curb on spending you could only
do so much damage before they could get
to Washington DC because they had a debt
cap
that's stupid you can beat it Tony you
and I could do this
spawn planes and be in DC for dinner
well with this show and with the
internet we don't even need to be in DC
we don't even need to be there we don't
even need to be in one place or the
other to to form a message and narrative
um boss man Texas here says CNN sucks
which brings me to you know now that
we're talking about the media and how
they're [__] up this whole debt
ceiling because they're playing right
into Republican hands here
um and really threatening the American
economy and on on national news
CNN's gonna hold a town hall with Trump
uh let me see if I can find the uh uh a
trailer for it while you're you're
making comment but you know what I don't
think we should have Traders doing Town
Halls that's just me maybe yeah I mean
where's the responsibility
where's the responsibility there
I mean this guy literally tried to
overthrow our government we know that
he's going to be prosecuted for it
eventually I mean some
freaking Century they'll get around to
it that's the problem that's what's been
wrong with this doj not acting faster
you know the the Brazilians got after
bolsonaro the next day
his people were in handcuffs the day
they pulled that [__] they were hauled
off to jail
you know
we really screwed up we really screwed
up with January 6 as as a country
I mean this guy is sitting
on a freaking news program being treated
like he's a legitimate candidate
he is not a legitimate candidate
I'm sorry somebody needs to introduce
this guy to freaking Kennedy is what
they need to do this is this is going
too damn far
well it absolutely is and here's CNN's
little trailer of it and the only reason
why I show it is for you to see it
for you to decide whether you want to
watch CNN ever again after this little
commercial right here it's not that long
it's 12 seconds watch former president
Donald Trump takes questions live from
CNN's Caitlin Collins and New Hampshire
GOP Primary voters their issues their
concerns their votes a CNN Republican
Presidential Town Hall May 10th at 94.
now you I I don't know about you but it
looks like they're trying to paint him
in the light a certain light now I'm
sure Ron DeSantis is absolutely [__]
infuriated by this and what this does
what this does is it opens up CNN to
have to hold the town hall for Ronda
Santos and they have to hold the town
hall for Joe Biden now
um that that is the rule now rather they
will or not or they're requested or not
I I don't know I don't know but I would
imagine
um you know and and you can you can call
it a boycott or whatever but really
honestly there's not you don't have to
boycott CNN you just turn the [__]
station to something else you turn it to
something else it's not that big of of a
deal you don't even have to make a big
hoopla about it on social media because
the fact of the matter remains is that
their ratings are going to be their
ratings but Texas Paul the funniest part
about this
I think is CNN is trying to be Fox 2.0
because Fox is on a Time Heals who knows
what's going to happen with this
smartmatic defamation lawsuit who knows
what's going to happen with this uh the
producer Abby rather that lawsuit has a
huge impact on Fox news or not but I
think I think what the fox the fox Maga
viewers
what's hilarious is news magazine are
are almost almost gone because of the
defamation amount that that Fox News had
to pay dominion and Dominion Sue in them
what is going to be hilarious this is
going to be the funniest part because
remember for years for years right
Wingers like else turn off CNN you
[__] libtard turn off CNN and now all
they're going to be watching others are
going to be watching is CNN I find that
funny I don't know I I always look for
the little nuggets that can make me
laugh and and at least enjoy the demise
of the Republican party I don't know
maybe it's just me
yeah man I I I I I tell you I I'm still
too pissed off to laugh I am I just I
just these guys are
this is just nauseating Tony Chris Licht
over there is you're right he's trying
to turn it into Fox he thinks he can
make money off of that and you know
they try to this go woke and go broke
thing you know that they're pushing well
uh
it's just the opposite anti will go
broke I just put a tweet out uh
yesterday
about old Elon Musk you know he's one of
the oligarchs that are pushing this this
hole back to the last century movement
he's funding all this [__] I mean that's
why he bought Twitter you know the
Saudis
didn't buy Twitter to make it a Open
Marketplace exchange of ideas no they
they want to put women in burcus that
that's what they want I mean and that's
what Elon Musk is doing Elon Musk didn't
have the scratch to buy Twitter he
didn't he made promises that he wouldn't
sell any more Tesla stock because his
investors were going to sue his ass
so he couldn't he could not fund the
purchase of Twitter
the Saudis made it possible
let me answer this let me ask you the
Saudis how do they feel about women's
rights
yeah um enjoy not [__] driving you
know enjoy oh I mean the writings are
women in public over there oh God I got
a comment here I gotta Show YouTube
um geopace P's last leg nice Name by the
way go fast no cash
yeah that's a good one ah God damn we
got a good audience we got the best
audience in the world
um here's a clip speaking of go woke go
broken women
um here is uh Jody Ernst the senator
from Iowa
um I guess I haven't seen this clip but
apparently she's trying to say woke as
many times as she can let's find out
instead of focusing on The lethality of
our men and women in uniform we've gone
woke oh Jesus Christ
how we're gonna plug them all in
why doesn't Elon Musk realize that he's
not aligned with these people like his
interest his financial interests are not
Executives you think yeah he he
personally is yeah professionally he's a
freaking [__] wow I mean he's been
crapping over his his customer
demographic forever I agree with you
they're 100 but that little apartheid
raised son [__] is exactly
our ties race some [__] apartheid raise
some [__] he was born in South Africa
under apartheid he is an apartheid some
[__]
some [__] I like it that guy has no
daylight between him and the Saudis none
none whatsoever
well um speaking of king of of wokism
here's Ron DeSantis
um and he's trying to take a question I
don't know if you noticed this but
Rhonda Santos doesn't take
um unsolicited questions very well he
just he doesn't quite understand
questions anymore because he's a [__]
idiot
um but this isn't long he's he's asked
about
why he's such a [__] bigot I mean in
basic terms and then he's is he gonna
focus on not being a bigot and then
guess what his answer is well we'll find
out let's listen some parents and
citizens may have a valid concern about
gender matters and transgender issues
with children in elementary schools and
unfairly in sports but there seems to be
a wave of extreme conservatism recently
that is totally anti-gay
as evident social media and even in
government with people like
congresswoman MTG
can you say here today you support more
mainstream human rights like gay
marriage and sexual orientation of
adults yes or no
so there's a lot in that I don't know
where you're necessarily going but look
what we've done with the schools is is
say you know it's inappropriate to be
having these students exposed to
curriculum about things like transgender
ideology it's wrong for teachers to
probe their sexuality but that's just
saying what's appropriate for uh for
education and we want to focus on the
basics uh we want yeah go ahead
did you ever take did you ever have
anything in your curriculum in school I
mean did you were you I mean I mean I I
was I was in a health class and we and
we learned about
um sex education anatomy anatomy And by
the you know you know what what what
what a wiener is what a JJ you know when
I where I grew up they were really you
know half-handed about this stuff you
know it's the whole
um have a banana put a condom on it type
thing uh you know again everything
everything affects these people's
sensitivity right
um I want to show you go ahead go ahead
where I was going with that Tony was
show me that curriculum anybody show me
that curriculum he's talking about I
didn't mean to interrupt that but you
know because I know her well I'm gonna
go to a clip of an of uh a bigot down in
in Florida
um and I wonder I wonder why and this
this person is aligned with Ron DeSantis
I would love to see how he's voted with
Ron DeSantis
um percentage-wise I'm sure it's damn
near 100 but uh let's listen to what
happened yesterday on the uh house floor
there in Florida listen to this and see
if you can spot the bigotry
it's glaring but just see things about
it be labeled as racist and
discrimination
without any without a response Isis the
Taliban and Al Qaeda those are the folks
who discriminate
we bombed a building in 2017 like we
never usually do we bombed it because
they threw homosexuals off that building
our terrorist enemies hate homosexuals
more than we do
you hear that I think he's
Republicans in the Florida house hate
homosexuals it's just it's just look
we're fascist but we're not as fascist
as the Taliban right like we're we're uh
yalkaida not Al-Qaeda right I think
that's what he's trying to say like
we're terrorists we're just not Muslim
terrorists so we don't hate homosexuals
as much as they do I mean it's a lot
it's a lot I mean they throw them on
buildings Texas Paul we just want to
legislate them out of existence here
that's all
we just talk about it here they do it
there right I mean right you can't say
we're the same just because we're saying
the same [__] you know right it's just
it's just we ain't done it yet because
well we don't think we get away with it
yet but right you know
well and that's the thing now here's
what I want to show you because um this
is important I'm going to wind it back
watch see this lady back here
watch this lady's face when he says it
because I didn't play it all the way
through let me show you what watch her
face watch her reaction and the reason
why is because not not like the words
that he's saying but
what he actually says is they hate
homosexuals watch her reaction
you do we bombed it because they threw
homosexuals off that building our
terrorist enemies hate homosexuals more
than we do
they're the ones who discriminate art
look at her reaction
whoa God damn I mean you couldn't you
couldn't give me a better meme of how
the country is reacting to this clip
that this person and Texas Paul this is
not the worst that they're saying on
state legislators for Lords this is not
they say much more vile much more
hateful [__] about Americans about our
fellow countrymen on the floor because
they hate them they [__] hate them
and and they want them not to exist they
hate them so much
yeah it's 100 true you know I was
talking about this the other day Tony
you know the oligarchs are on the Move
they're funding all of this [__] I mean
these guys you know like you know I was
pointing out uh uh Chris pole house you
remember the Nazis in in uh in Ohio
in front of them the one that doesn't
wear the mask the only one that doesn't
wear the mask he goes by Hammer yeah
Chris Paul house
that [__] isn't free and that is funded
funded by oligarchs in this country they
think they have a handle on this they
think that they're just appealing to the
races out there and you know they can
keep their base together through some
pretty shitty times for the Republican
party I mean the Republican Party looks
really shitty right now because they are
really shitty right now so they're going
to Pander to these Races they think they
have control of this they do not
they do not you cannot put this [__]
back in the horse
you know I mean once these freaking nuts
get out there and start doing this [__]
it it doesn't it doesn't go backwards
Tony not until we start putting them in
prison
and that's why I said something that
made a lot of people upset and I'll say
it again I think we need to retune some
of our rights I mean all of our rights
are on a scale not a single right
guaranteed in the constitution is
unabridged in some fashion and I think
we need to take a look at hate speech I
think we need to take a look at what we
call protected speech in this country
because this is just going too far every
other first world nation has looked at
this and said you can't do this because
it goes to Dark Places and we sit here
like dumbasses saying it'll be okay you
know I mean it's not gonna [__] be
okay
and these people have no control over
them I mean you think Marjorie Trader
green
has one bit of a freaking leash on these
animals no no she didn't she doesn't
even know how to control her mouth let
alone control a group of people here's
Matt Walsh speaking of [__] hateful
vile human pieces of trash
um here's Matt Walsh now he was doing
his show and this person down here
Sheriff Brockman I don't know who it is
I I have no idea I don't even know if
it's a real Sheriff but the question was
during the show this is a comment during
the show and it this looks like it's on
Facebook to me maybe I don't know I
can't really tell maybe it's on Twitter
because it's an app sign [__] I don't
know the point is this the question that
sheriff Brockman is posing to Matt Walsh
in real time during his show says do you
think Jesus would treat the trans
movement with the same amount of hate
that you do so think about that question
what this person is asking Matt Walsh
during his little who who knows what the
diatribe is I'm sure it's a diatribe
about how he hates homosexuals in the
lgbtq Community as the representative
down in Florida said that we're not as
bad as the Taliban or Al Qaeda because
we don't hate him that much to throw
them off buildings we just want to
legislate them out of existence he's
asking would Jesus because Matt Walsh
claims to be a Christian here all the
time would he would Jesus hate
the trans movement as much as he does
here's Matt Walsh's response
here's his here's his response on
Twitter this is his official account
the answer to his question is yes Jesus
Texas ball would hate the trans because
we all know what Jesus would do Jesus
would hate for sure there's no way
there's no instance in the Bible where
he's spreading a message of inclusion
and love I I've never seen that part of
Jesus before in the Bible now I want to
I want to tell you what I said I said
you're not a Christian you're [__]
trash now I'm not a Christian either I'm
an atheist but frankly I think Jesus
and God the Christian God that Matt
Walsh claims to worship
I think
he would think I'm more Christian than
Matt Walsh and I don't even believe in
God or Jesus what do you think what
what's your take on this garbage from
Matt Walsh where he's saying that Jesus
would hate you're you're muted there
it's clear he never read the damn Bible
I mean
we know what the answer is to this
question no Jesus wouldn't hate them
because Jesus professed to not hate
anybody even the people that were
killing him he professed to not hate
but I hate this comparison Tony I hate
this comparison because it always comes
with an assumption that well there's
something wrong with this person would
Jesus love him right there's nothing
Christianity is one of the first
religions to have a problem with this
I mean this is this this is not normal
and even early Christianity but if you
get before 1950
Christianity didn't have a problem with
this
they they didn't it wasn't even the
Notre Dame Bible
they had to put it in to hate these
people
you know I mean the sacred ring was one
of the considered one of the greatest
fighting forces to ever exist the the
Greeks
um had had a fighting force that was
made up of homosexual married men
it was the husband and the husband they
paired them together there was 150
couples it was one of the greatest it
was one of the only forces to defeat the
Spartans
I mean they handed the Spartans their
ass man these guys were [__]
ferocious
because they loved each other and they
cared for each other it never used to be
a problem Tony
these people are sick they're twisted
and demented and I hate those
comparisons because it makes that
assumption well why wouldn't Jesus love
this person well there's nothing
freaking wrong with this person they're
just a person
human mind no no we shouldn't dehumanize
anyone but I'll tell you that um there
is some footage of Matt Walsh at the Met
Gala have you have you seen some of the
outfits from the Met Gala and I'm not
going to go through all the outfits
they're [__] kind of crazy right I
mean there's some of them you're like
what the [__] is that is that fashion
and I I didn't know that that was fair
I'm not I'm not I'm not big on fashion
Texas Paul man what do I know so you
know I kind of keep my nose out of the
Met Gala but Matt Walsh apparently
showed up at the gala here is exclusive
footage here on the Tony Michaels
podcast of it let me show you
he's hungry
get a photo get a photo yeah
that [__] cockroach uh Matt Walsh no
I'm just kidding I I stole the joke um
someone posted that on Twitter here's
here's the um here's the and she says
Matt Walsh has arrived at the Met Gala
conjure uh wrote that so I stole the
joke but I thought it was funny so I I'd
include it I figured the audience would
like it so I'm gonna give her credit
here
um you know I didn't I didn't see that
one before I I actually thought that
Matt Walsh was at the Met Gala because I
I tell you these these freaking Blue
Blood oligarchs are hugging these people
close man it's like they're really
trying to and if you look at these old
oligarch bastards they're all at death's
door
they're all at death store I mean it's
like they're having surgery just to keep
the meat on you know I mean they're
from falling off their damn face they
are about to die and man I tell you what
they have made it their life's purpose
before they die to shove this country
back to 1950 when they could be
massaging this dicks and hate on
everybody oh
oh talking about 1950
I have a a clip for you Texas ball great
transition this is the superintendent of
schools in Oklahoma I just want to ask
you first
um this I mean you know this looks
reasonable right it's in an office he's
got books on the table he's got the
American flag the Oklahoma flag I mean
alert looks like he's going to deal with
some important issues here listen to
what this [__] says it's only 41
seconds see if you can spot the fashion
in this clip here
Oklahomans we have a clear choice in
front of us
when it comes to our schools do we want
the radical ideology into our classroom
that pushes gender theory that pushes
graphic pornography in order to perform
a social experiment on our kids or do we
want the US Constitution do we want
documents like The Federalist Papers and
the Bible so that our kids understand
our history and how our government was
put together what I did not know that
the Bible is an American history
document I had no idea now here's what
I'll tell you taxable I'm not opposed to
the the Holy Bible all the versions
being in a public school library
honestly I think the Quran should be
right next to it and if we're going to
make these books available make them
available but if you're scared of
pornography and books the Bible is the
last one you want to be [__] pimping
out there is the Bible about nudity and
pornography and murder and genocide I
mean there's a few of those things in
that [__] book
um go ahead go ahead I had a
conversation with a couple they believe
this [__] this straw man [__] he's
putting I'm telling you this curriculum
doesn't exist he says your choice is
between this curriculum that does not
[__] exist anywhere on this in this
country and what I want to do [__]
straw man Governor Stitt just did the
same thing I passed a law and I'm
signing my law that says you can't have
gender affirming surgery for kids Tony
how many people do you know that are
just straight just just straight as can
be that have money for elective
surgeries
I I mean not many
maybe I mean it's very few people have
to save like they're right freaking
whole lives together or they have job I
mean well they have to get a shitload of
credit cards to put it on one of the
other exactly exactly it's really
freaking rare people cannot afford this
[__] unless you're in one specific
little class in our society it's not
happening a lot
so tell me how the hell are
I don't know regular people with
transgender kids supposed to be able to
afford these surgeries
they're not covered by insurance
it's a law it's a law in search of a
problem
well I mean it's a law and in search of
exclusion is what it is
um here's a clip uh from a school board
and I believe this in is in Florida let
me double check here I think this is in
Florida uh it's moms of Liberty I'm
pretty sure it's in Florida but Mom's a
liberty here they and she's running for
uh school board and someone questions
her in the crowd now this is a longer
clip but I think it's worth it to show
you how to undermine their stupid
[__] fascist white Christian
nationalist narrative watch
in the school district
uh well in in general like yes I do
and so what is it what is it in your
mind
so let me just say that I do
yes I I understand what you're where you
are coming from that you want to see all
children you know treated equally I do
too I don't care who comes into my
classroom I don't care what color they
are I don't care what their sexual
orientation is
tell me what the Dei program is that you
have a problem with now Dei is um uh
inclusion and Equity reversity Equity
that's right that's right sorry about
that it's Dei diversity equity and
inclusion and um they're claiming that
this boxes out white children this is
where the white Christian nationalism
comes in but this person who is talking
to this moms of Liberty I don't know if
you noticed it had her on her hind heels
immediately when she says what is Dei to
you what is this policy what is this
curriculum that you're speaking of and
she can't Define it but watch how she
absolutely undermines her and she
doesn't have to you know get at her and
describe what's happening now that you
have an issue with and then be quick
because we have to move on to this
airline that we need to carry on with
the questions I don't
but I just think it's important and this
is not a passion and I don't and I know
we're tempted to clap and laugh it's
really not about that this really is
about being transparent and it really is
about the kids so would you please just
explain as far as you understand it what
does the devianti platform and program
here at East Stroudsburg Area School
District
and if you're not sure it's okay to say
you're not sure I'm not sure what it is
here at East Stroudsburg so she doesn't
know she's running for school board
she's trying to be the board member of
this school and this this school
district she doesn't know what the Dei
policy even is she's against it even
though she doesn't know what it is or
what it means but wait Texas Paul I
think I know that that moms of Liberty
is kind of like the um the the the the
the female proud boys here and the
reason why is because they have no real
principle other than white Christian
nationalism wait until she says the
quiet part out loud here what
if
you don't have specific knowledge of
this particular School District what is
what is it what is it in your mind
platform does
and if you're not sure that's okay too
she's struggling
can't do it say it say it out loud
yeah that
they're going to be
children that are in need to feel bad of
who they are because
they're not of
um
Texas Paul that seems like it's really
scared that there's some children out
there that aren't going to feel
um what is it included included hmm and
you know the hilarious part about that
is I know what Dei is I happen to know I
can explain what Dei is it's not quotas
it's not equal opportunity it's not any
of those things that they hate so damn
much
where they say oh you're keeping white
kids up no we're not
Dei specifically is to make
people of color aware that opportunities
are out there and that they can apply
for them to find Qualified applicants
and and here's the thing they're not
just saying oh uh we we we're we need to
we need to hit a uh we need an
African-American person in this spot no
that's not what they're saying they're
saying you kid are on the honor roll did
you know that there is this thing
happening over here that you qualify for
that's the root of Dei diversity equity
and inclusion is to make sure that
everybody knows everyone they can play
all of them everyone every single one of
them but listen to what this is this is
great here because here is the quiet
part out loud listen to this
worries but speak behind this one like
what are you would have been fearful of
when you say that kids are going to feel
feel bad about one
so I think that they're going to be made
to feel bad
they are not a person of color
what would the guys guys
this is this is uncomfortable but it's
necessary and I appreciate the fact that
you're even courageous enough to be
honest because many people say I will I
will tell you this I here it is
actually it was
strongly recommended to me that I do not
attend tonight
and
I do not agree with that I wanted to be
here and I want to share that I want to
have it
Texas ball the reason why they told her
not to attend that meeting is because
exactly what happens is it will be
exposed what they truly want they don't
want they do not want white parents to
know that oh my God you mean there's
opportunities out there for people of
color and and my my dumb ass white kid
might not get those opportunities
because there's a smarter person of
color than me that than their than my
child that's that's what it is that's
what all this is it's white Christian
nationalism it's racism it's [__]
bigotry it's all rooted in that and they
don't want to say the quiet part out
loud that's why they didn't want her to
go to that meeting that's why the moms
of Liberty suggested she not go and take
questions because they knew what the
questions were they'd be questioning the
exact idea of what they're doing
mm-hmm absolutely right absolutely right
I'm 100 the ones that know that are in
the know
are trying to keep everything all white
all white all white they don't want
programs that let everybody know this is
what's available to you they don't want
that they want it to be College like it
used to be you know before Ronald Reagan
uh came along they you know college was
cheap man it was damn near free you know
you basically had to pay for your room
and board
and and and you know here comes Reagan
when people of color wanted to go and
he's like hey man let's start charging
out the ass for that well why to keep it
all white all white all white that's why
you know I mean it's the ones in the
know that's really their strategy but
the ones that don't know your average
Republican voter
they're just a racist ass hick that's it
that they're just sorry ass racists and
this sounds like something that they can
say well you're being racist to me
because you know you're telling all them
little dark colored kids that they could
go to this school but you didn't tell my
little Jim Bob he could go [__] Jim
Bob was told
Jim Bob was told Jim Bob didn't make the
[__] grades is what happened there
right Jim Bob's an idiot because you're
an idiot that's that's the problem here
um Theron state says moms of Liberty
equals clanned Karen Hood
I love that oh my God Clan Clan Garnet
I'm stealing that [__] I don't care what
you say that's mine now thank you for
the comment we got the best audience in
the world speaking of uh Clan the clan
here's Tommy mcmurty I don't know Tommy
mchatron here he's talking about uh
Budweiser did you notice that Budweiser
stock is up but uh they're really
they're really excited that Bud Light
sales went down last month they're
they're not they're not playing the long
game here because they don't understand
uh to affect Bud Light they need more
than one months of drop in sales uh I
don't know if they know that and the
other thing too is I don't know if they
looked at all the sales numbers of
Budweiser and Anheuser-Busch are beer
sales in general
um but anyways it in facts don't um
affect these people but here's this guy
he's on the pulpit man he's preaching
two two uh Christian quote Christians
it's the same Christians that Matt Walsh
are listen to what he says about Bud
Light but the ending on the Dr Pepper oh
my God this guy listen it's 2023 and
this training stuff is everywhere and
it's absolutely revolting and let me
just say this to make me feel good I've
always let me just say this to make me
feel good you couldn't package it up any
better for these fragile white [__]
incel men than that I just want to say
this to make me feel good Texas fall oh
my God I know you see what's coming here
because he uses a derogatory term
towards trans people right which when I
when I when I was young a [__] was
something that fell out underneath your
car when it was a piece of [__] that's
it's a transmission that that's what
that is but they've turned that word
into a derogatory term
um but you know where this is going
right he's gonna talk about Dylan
Mulvaney in the Bud Light can
you're on mute
sorry bud I can't muting it so that I
can call
uh yeah you know exactly where he's
going man I mean it's painfully obvious
that there this is their this is where
they have been tuned to go we got
another we got another something that
these hillbilly [__] don't know [__]
about so we can tell them all of us evil
[__] about it and they won't know so
let's go ahead and run on and and talk
about some you know
transsexual people and tell them a bunch
of [__] about their groomers and this
that and the other when we're the ones
really banging the Boy Scouts I mean
it's just
and again it gets
again it just gets it go ahead go ahead
it gets exasperating because it's doing
what it's exactly meant to do make us
have this damn conversation instead of
dealing with the things that we need to
be dealing with which the people that
are funding this don't want us dealing
with right you know they don't want us
dealing with
wealth inequity they don't want us to
deal with the fact that we have a real
Health Care problem in our country I
mean we have a lot of people that have
really shitty health because they don't
get regular doctor care they don't get
regular treatment for for programs you
know how many people we have on a damn
dialysis that didn't have to be on
dialysis or somebody had just diagnosed
them as a type 2 diabetic
you know I mean there's a shitload of
people but I mean I you could you could
go down a list it's not just
um just dialysis I mean they're banning
Women's Health Care they're they're
banning they're banning the right in
States uh for children and Medicaid and
Medicare recipients from getting
um uh Health Care a mental health care
they keep yelling and screaming that the
gun issue is mental health care yet they
do nothing they stand back and do
nothing but I'm telling you if we don't
if we don't root these people out and
show the country who the [__] these
people are and what they're trying to do
in their government our government We
the People then we're not gonna change
[__] we're gonna keep the same
old-fashionist in power in these state
legislators these City councils these
school boards and the United States
House of Representatives and we're gonna
keep on this trudge towards all out
fascism listen to what this [__] says
about Dr Pepper
hated the Bud Light company but you know
what it's felt pretty good this week
watching them lose billions of dollars
false not even close die good luck dummy
I do I man I hope I hope they do I hope
I I can't imagine a straight man
drinking Bud Light right now
what the he can't imagine a straight man
you this this is this is their Del this
is their real delusion Texas Paul
this is their real delusion
um go ahead take your break I I'll I'll
continue here
um so here here is this guy
um listen to what he says about Dr
Pepper
I mean you you name there's not a drink
out there you all know how much I like
ghosts they put a trainee on their cans
I'll be cured
done
I don't care Dr Pepper you know whatever
Dr Pepper so if Dr Pepper
partners with anyone he doesn't like
well then he's gonna not drink Dr Pepper
well friend I I hate to tell you I tell
you friend but Anheuser-Busch uh owns
just about every goddamn alcoholic
beverage in this country and this is
where they fall this is the stupidest
thing that they do and honestly
I'm telling you more than anything these
people are vile pieces of [__] they're
going to continue to be vile pieces of
[__] this guy here
but here's the thing
is that there is an opening
there is an opening
for the American left okay and I'm not
talking about
socialist
I mean we can we can certainly Ally with
the Democratic socialists I'm not just
talking about progressives right however
you identify on the left [__] the
independence
and moderates in this country and
anti-trumpers and anti-discrimination
like who hate [__] like this
who can't stand these people preaching
this [__]
in a church
I'm telling you I'm telling you we can
all rap we can all wrap our arms around
this idea that we're not gonna just
throw out all of our corporations and
all of our culture with beer or any of
these products we can wrap our arms
around it we can partner I'm telling you
Corporate America doesn't like these
fascists I don't I don't Texas ball I'm
these corporations you know this whole
woke culture won't go broke they're
terrified that these [__] idiots are
gonna continue to demonize them because
they want to operate as a profitable
company in a capitalist an economic
system that we have in America and I
don't know you know sometimes the enemy
of your enemy is your friend
and I'm just saying that maybe just
maybe the left should start to embrace
corporations and start to embrace
capitalism a little bit more than we do
and stop bashing it for a little bit we
can partner and what we can do is get
these fascists to crawl back underneath
their Rock because I'm telling you I'm
telling you that like like Ronda
Santos's war on Disney what the what a
stupid [__] idea that is just like
these [__] idiots war on
Anheuser-Busch what a dumb idea that is
it's just not going to work out in their
favor I don't give a [__] what any of
them say what they say about the beer
sales last month wait until the end of
the [__] summer and we'll see what
the beer sales at Bud Light say okay
this is this is [__] ridiculous it's
absolutely asinine and we as a country
can stand behind our culture now I know
you might not like
um standing up for Anheuser-Busch or or
Bud Light or whatever and it's not even
standing up for them all it is is saying
this is stupid what a dumb idea so if
you drink a Bud Light that makes you gay
again your hatred your hatred for for
the lgbtq community dude makes you look
like you're closeted this guy here
that's all I'm saying maybe
you know and I'll be honest with you
they've been expecting us I've had
several people tell me right-wingers and
over social media put in asinine
comments about you're just mad because
we're hurting Bud Light
no I'm not [__] no I'm not
kill them kill the entire [__]
Corporation they have been one of your
most loyal most trustworthy [__]
contributors for decades
I have been screaming about
Anheuser-Busch and the Bush family
[__] kill that company
and I you know I hope these companies
get what they deserve you created this
Frankenstein monster you funded it you
made it
lie in the bed with these sons of
[__] Disney you know I talk [__]
about Disney whipping them and this that
and the other Disney's been [__]
pumping the right wing full of money
forever
[__] them up guys do it tear their asses
up that's right you know well that's
what I'm saying Texas Paul that's what
I'm saying is that for for decades and
decades in this country these
corporations have have played both sides
of the aisle and here's what I mean by
this is they give a shitload of money to
to appear to to be inclusionary
capitalist to Democrats and they give a
shitload of money to Republicans to make
sure that they get their taxes cut on
the back end because they want to stuff
their money full of are their pockets
full of [__] money and and I I'm
telling you I'm telling you maybe maybe
just maybe some of these right-wing
boycotts Will Wait these corporations up
and go you know what maybe we shouldn't
be maybe we shouldn't be so concentrated
on [__] trying to trying to Lobby to
save our tax dollars maybe what we
should be doing is being good stewards
of business in this country will support
us maybe that's what maybe that's what
the [__] you should be doing nailed it
Tony freaking nailed it that's where I
was going with that exactly so you got
your tax cuts you got a portion of your
profits to stay in your pocket good for
you how's that going to feel when
[__] Bud Light tanks how's that going
to feel when you have no profit
you know I mean that's exactly where I'm
at Tony exactly what you were just
saying is you know these guys to save a
little bit of money on taxes have been
pumping these people full of cash
and now the worm is turned
they are on you okay there's a good job
enjoy losing you're not you're not
losing a portion of your profits you're
losing your profits
well you know because why because
15 percent of the country's LBG lb lgbtq
and they drink beer so you wanted to
sell them some beer so you had an
outreach program so now they're gonna
[__] your company up
well I think that's right and I think a
lot of people are making economic
decisions I got a video that's going
around the internet over this I want to
say hi to all the sparklers out there we
had a lot of howl uh Sparks fans that
join us here every Tuesday Texas Balsa
just want to give the sparklers a shout
out
um why we're why we're getting to the
Taylor Swift video Gabe Sanchez is still
having trouble with this internet so I'm
hoping he can join us I was going to
save the Taylor Swift thing
um for him have you seen this video of
Taylor Swift yet no I haven't I haven't
great I'm I'm super excited that we're
gonna get your reaction here of this
video now um Taylor Swift didn't endorse
or be against anyone in the 2016
election
um but in 2020 we know that she came out
against Trump and she spoke out against
Trump and we never really got an insight
into the decision of how that was done
but here here is here is the video of
Taylor Swift and her family uh
discussing the prospect of her coming
out against Trump uh watch we've not
gotten involved with politics all
religion yeah but this is on the home
front and also
the presidential election
I was in such a horrendous place
that I wasn't gonna pop my head out of
the sandwich
these aren't your dad's celebrities and
these aren't your dad's Republicans boom
I don't know if you just got that but
Taylor Swift put the old folks in the
room in their place like look you're
talking about Bob Hope and you're
talking and you're talking about a time
where the Republicans weren't talking
about
legislating people out of existence
they're talking about they're talking
about genocide of a of a small group of
people in this country and it doesn't
stop there they're trying to ban Women's
Health Care they want to burn books
she's sounding the alarm Bells here
um to her Inner Circle now Jesus Christ
Tony they keep saying they want to
repeal women's right to vote they say it
out loud all the time they just haven't
acted on they don't want Taylor Swift's
audience to vote they don't want Taylor
Swift's audience to vote
and so let me let me let me finish
playing this here because I want you to
see
um when when she digs her heels in here
because they're trying to convince her
not to do this Texas while they're
trying to convince her just sing okay
it's the whole just dribble the ball
LeBron James you don't need to be saying
what your political beliefs are just
dribble right just play the football
would you please play the sports ball
it's the same thing in this instance
where they're just trying to get Taylor
Swift to look just yeah that's not what
happened to the Dixie Chicks right well
um you know Taylor Swift really came in
uh into popularity right during that
time
um when the Dixie Chicks I don't know if
you uh remember you probably do where
they spoke out against the the war in uh
in Iraq against George W bush and they
were pulling them off country stations
because people were like oh you are
against the war which now it's kind of
funny Texas ball because they're against
the war
they're against the war they're against
what the [__] I just I you know you
can't help but
um you know but really actually if you
think about it which is why I can't
America
I can't listen to the [__] anymore I
can't I cannot listen to this [__]
anymore I just can't I I think actually
I think actually a lot of country
artists
um you know some of these [__] idiots
like Travis Tritt and John Rich are
[__] bigots but I think the majority
of country artists are not are not that
way I believe the majority of country
artists like Chris Stapleton he is not
that way Marjorie Taylor green bowed at
the feet of Chris Stapleton uh for the
Super Bowl and didn't even realize that
Chris Stapleton was like you goddamn
right black lives matter in 2020 he's
like you goddamn right and I'm Gonna
Stand by that doesn't understand that
Chris Stapleton not only not only is he
a country artist but he understands that
the majority of his sound and the
majority of his art comes from black
people he understands that and he said
it in interviews and you can hear it in
his voice so I I don't believe that
country music is all bigoted and I don't
believe that it's always been bigoted
yeah it's not the artist though Tony
it's not there's there's enough artists
that I could find out there I could find
some music it's the entire establishment
have you turned on a radio station
lately oh no I I'm not saying I'm not
saying that country music radio in these
rural areas aren't placating to the
races bigoted audiences absolutely and
they're having DJs that say absolute
vile [__] things about people uh on
their radio stations I'm talking about
the music I'm talking about the art
itself
um but here let me finish with this
Taylor Swift because I think sorry no no
one of the most um one of the most
unique things in this in this clip is
we're her dad because there's a moment
where her dad says something
um that that really gives away what is
happening in this country and again this
isn't right now this isn't in this time
this is for the 2020 uh lead up to the
2020 election launch imagine if we came
to you so hey we've got this idea that
we could halve the number number of
people that come to you next tour the
other thing just from a security so you
think Taylor Swift comes out against
Trump I don't care I don't care to write
that
there's something that I know is right
and you guys
I need to be on the right side of
history and if he doesn't win then at
least I I at least I tried so here's the
here's the problem I just want to read
you what I wrote and I'm going to try to
start I just really want you to know
that this is important to me
yes I've read the entire thing and the
bottom line right now I'm terrified I'm
the guy that went out and bought armored
cars
that's her father Texas Paul and he said
I'm terrified his response is I'm the
guy who went out and bought Armored Cars
what would they need to be armored from
Texas Paul what could it possibly be
that they need to be armored from and
why is it feelings well that is true
um and that's and that's the thing is
that it is astonishing and stunning that
not not today in this time but this was
about I guess this was uh this would
have been 2018 2019 when Trump announced
um I think it's 2019 to be quite honest
so we're talking almost four years ago
or over four years ago
that her father was like if you say this
these supporters of trump are gonna try
to shoot and kill you like that's his
first reaction I'm terrified that
they're gonna shoot and kill you because
he says I'm the one who ordered Armored
Cars I think it's stunning it's stunning
that even even Taylor Swift's dad gets
it now the one of the managers and he
kind of has an accent there I think his
British accent he says he's talking
about the economic issues he says this
will half your audience I don't know if
anyone's paying attention but uh Taylor
Swift just opened up her new concert
this year I believe it was in February
February and March and it was in Phoenix
did you know Texas ball that more people
showed up in Phoenix Arizona for her
open than the Super Bowl holy [__]
her coming out against I I don't I don't
I don't want to hurt anyone's feelings
especially the haters in the chat but
Trump is highly unpopular
no one likes that [__] besides
about 10 percent of the country who are
delusional and cult members that's it
everyone else hates that some [__]
and it didn't affect her economically at
all matter of fact she's getting more
money because she spoke out and her fans
wanted her to
yeah you know even if she'd lost half
her audience she'd still have the
freaking largest audience in the world
but right you know I'm not I'm not
encouraging her to do this I'm really
not I don't think she needs to go and
get herself canceled I mean I love that
people speak out and and whatnot but and
if she wants to do it that's her
business you know I mean I'm on her
dad's side I hear this from my wife all
the time Paul you don't have to go there
you don't have to say that this is going
to hurt you in the long run you need to
I gotta be who I am so if she's got to
be who she is God bless her
you know [__] I may have to go buy a
Taylor Swift album I don't know
you know
but her dad's got a point Tony
her dad has a point you know you can't
put bumper stickers on your car around
here
unless they're Trump stickers where I
live
you know they they just
they'll vandalize your car
right I mean these people are low life
scum
they are they are
and they they want you to be scared and
[__] and it's freaking ridiculous now I
want to show you the ending and the
reason why I want to show the ending is
because I don't want people to think
that that the Dad's reaction here is is
based uh in anything that would be
pro-trump or pro-a-certain politics
um he's just worried about her safety
and I want to show you How It Ends
because I think this moment
um is probably what this uh made the
decision that she would do this I think
it's kind of um
it's crazy to see this behind the scenes
that it took this much effort for her to
get her opinion out there that she had
to convince all these handlers
um to have this opinion but here is and
how measured and how measured she is
about politics and her opinions
um in this space that we live in but
here is here's the ending here watch
this I worry for her safety as much as
anybody does maybe more
it really is a big deal
she votes against against fair pay for
women she votes against the
reauthorization of the of the violence
against women act which is just
basically protecting us from domestic
abuse and stalking stalking
she votes she thinks that that if you're
a gay couple or even if you look like a
gay couple you should be allowed to be
kicked out of a restaurant it's really
basic human rights and it's right and
wrong at this point and I can't see
another commercial
and see her
disguising these policies behind the
words Tennessee Christian values those
aren't Tennessee Christian values I live
in Tennessee I am Christian that's not
what we stand for
she's talking about Marshall Blackburn
there she was in the race in 2020 as
well but watch the ending here as her
dad and her Embrace I need to do this I
need you to just
I didn't need you to forgive me for
doing it because I'm doing it
here's the Embrace
um again it was in the in the 2020 race
where Marsha Blackburn was running for
Senate and she's and she's she outright
said look I can't stand back and let
this [__]
talk about taking away people's basic
human right and their humanity and their
decency away from them in public because
because of Christian values that's not
Christian values um so I I I don't know
who released this video I don't know
where it came to light again this has
been several years ago that this
happened
um but
um I I I just want to say that Taylor
Swift is a great artist she's a great
musician you wouldn't have the following
that you have if she didn't have the
talent she had but I I also want to tell
her that the country supports you this
and and and I know that's obvious in her
ticket sales but at the sentiment behind
human rights we support you so I and I
again I don't know if she released this
I'm not really sure where this video
came from
um but it was going around this morning
on the internet I thought it was great
to show
um because of what we're going through
every single day year in this country
where the theocracy is trying to
put their [__] into the minority or
into the ideology from the minority side
uh let me let me go to I've got another
clip I want to show here Texas Paul that
I got to get in
um and I know you probably want to do
commentary on this as well did you
notice the last criminal of Scotland so
[Laughter]
um
did you notice the last criminal of
Scotland so here's the thing there's a
there's a trial going on a defamation uh
and rape trial e Gene Carroll makes
these claims against Donald Trump it
looks like she's gonna have a successful
verdict here everything is pointing to
that because uh Donald Trump and his
attorneys can't make a decent argument
nor can Donald Trump make a decent
argument on why he can't appear he says
he can't afford it he's broke or some
[__]
but he flew over to Scotland he flew
over to Scotland Texas Paul
um does that make any sense to you that
he doesn't have money to go to this
trial but he has money to go pretend
like he's using a shovel in Scotland and
I say pretend because that's what he's
doing yeah
you know man I
I'm almost glad he didn't show up to
this trial yeah because you know I mean
it really just needed to be a trial
they really needed to just be able to
listen to evidence and if he'd be in the
circus you mean not a circus yeah the
the media would have turned it into a
freaking circus and talked about
everything but what was really going on
you know I you know legal AF over over
on my desk man they they
've got a great show and they were going
through Eugene Carroll's testimony and
they were like hey guys this wasn't the
best testimony
you know this may not be in the bag
hold my beer comes Joe tapioca you know
I mean this guy he's put on the worst
possible case he could have possibly he
literally had this handed to him
because of some of the things that
Eugene Carroll testified to you know I
mean he could have gone a smart route
but he was so freaking stupid about
being misogynistic and trying to put her
on trial
that he just blew his own case and and a
professional they're professional rake
steppers I mean come on this is what
they do they face plan every single time
and and so him you know he's got the
shittiest cheapest attorneys in the
world so his argument on one hand is I
can't afford this and then you're right
he turns around and flies to freaking
Scotland
because he says he's got to be there for
the for the groundbreaking of a new golf
course what
you can't afford to be at your trial but
you're building a new golf course you
think the judge doesn't [__] see that
come on oh yeah you know you know the
judge has seen this from the bench and
I'm sure the jeds saw this picture
um if you guys wanted to laugh today
this is hilarious I don't give a [__]
who you are this is so funny that they
dressed him up in this oh my God don't
you know he was pissed when they were
like no you got to put on the hat it's
gonna your [__] hair is gonna be over
it's gonna be cold as [__] he had no
idea and they gave him this hat there's
no way Texas while you cannot convince
me that they planned on him wearing that
hat
no man he stepped outside in that wind
and his hair's got you noticed that his
hair's gotten worse oh it looks like
I mean nasty I mean you know it's not
like he's going you know like bald
people don't look bad you know they just
look like they're going bald this guy
looks like he's got like a medical issue
or something
medical issues but there's and it's so
bad they had to put a beanie cap on him
which looks ridiculous
well let me show you let me show you an
outshot of this picture because I zoomed
in on it there's the there's the the uh
the grandpa jacket now I don't mean to
offend you a Texas ball if you got a
jacket like this but I because I have a
couple grandpa I I have a couple Grandpa
jackets like this they're warm and
they're designed for you to stay warm
but not look cool at all
um I got car parts do you notice his his
shovel is gold here so they planned on
him having a golden shovel but but this
hat and this [__] jacket holy [__]
but you notice there's no dirt in the
shovel right now now I want to show you
I want to show you oh my God
they are the funniest goddamn audience
on Earth okay so I'm not just gonna show
you pictures of
um of the Cheeto desk you and I are
pretending how to dig
um here's here's another here's another
outshot of the picture this is the one
we used uh Gabe Sanchez used for the
um the thing today and of course they
all have gold shovels here but there he
is in his in his little hat and his
gloves and his in his jacket his gold
shovel that's empty
um standing outside for the golf course
thing but I want to show you the video
text as well because he said something
in the video and of course he's gotta
say something that's just [__] stupid
of course he does why wouldn't he but I
want you to watch the video and tell me
Texas ball because I know you've used
the shovel in your life probably this
week you use the shovel
um so I wanna I want I want you to tell
me if it looked looks like Donald Trump
has ever in his life actually used a
shovel for anything other than a photo
op here's here's the video
he says I'm going to throw it at the
press or throw it right in their faces
is what he said now I'm gonna play this
on a loop and so we can see it as we're
giving commentary so the one guy
standing next to him obviously has never
used a shovel up either and and this guy
here in the white hat has to actually
put dirt in his shovel and I'm I'm I'm
sure that it was before he put this
guy's dirt in the shovel he put Donald
Trump's have you ever stood like this
using a shovel Texas ball have you ever
stood like that using a shovel you're
muted there
um and and I I don't know this looks a
little weird that he's standing like
that using a shovel
this guy is just I mean everything he
does there there's
this is why all of his businesses die
this is why I mean
these moments are supposed to be your
film footage these moments are supposed
to be your selling point and he's
standing there looking like he's trying
to squeeze one out you know I mean he's
like he's he's got that that Louie body
dementia leaning forward kind of thing
and his knees are locked and he's he
just he he looks like
he's got no clue man he looks like he's
got no clue and he's been grifting this
[__] forever and and you can he
obviously has something going on with
the woman next to him because he cannot
get his attention off of her right I
mean this whole time that he's supposed
to be flogging his new golf course he's
supposed to be making his Aces here
buddy he is supposed to really be
selling this [__] for the news and the
his media people to use this as clips
and [__] like that he cannot quit
messing with her the whole freaking time
look at him talking to her again yeah so
so Gary asked what's with the white
shoes my guess is because he's on the
golf course
um he thought it was a good idea to wear
golf shoes even though he he clearly is
not golfing or shoveling for that matter
he's not shoveling either Texas ball I
mean you know so um you know I guess
maybe it's it's appropriate but the
[__] hat the [__] hat gets me holy
[__] you know he was he's pissed off
today that we're even showing this video
with him wearing that stupid [__] hat
come on that's a dumb hat right or am I
crazy it is it is and the white shoes
Gary you're dead right about that you
know I golf there's a golf bag right
over there I haven't played in a long
time but I do go they make those shoes
in brown and black
if you want Wing chips or you want
Italian or you want I mean you can get
golf shoes anyway you do not have to
dress like a 70s Dad when you golf you
don't you don't have to you can also buy
shovels that aren't gold too that don't
look pretentious because my guess is
these aren't actual gold shovels my
guess is they had them spray paint them
gold before he got there as well yeah
they do that with those ground bacon
shovels all the time they pen they take
get some gold spray paint and spray them
down I just can't he's failing so bad at
this
and you know he's had to go to a bunch
of these groundbreakings you know I mean
oh yeah this is not the first this is
not the first fake shoveling he's done
not the first time that he's fake
shoveling are you using a shovel or even
holding a shovel I'm sure that's the
only reason why he's holding it the way
he's holding it in some manner in
respect is because he's been told
several times before that's not how you
hold the you know all the shovel like a
pencil sir I mean it's not like you're
trying to hold your [__] in from [__] in
your diaper it's it's a shovel and
you're shoveling
um I just I it's [__] hilarious that
he's he you know and I never understood
this Texas ball because I grew up in
rule White America and worldwide America
[__] hates hate city Folk especially
city Folk from from the east coast and
Manhattan they [__] hate them like
there's a goddamn song talking about how
hey I got a friend in New York and he
it's it's a Hank Williams Jr song Right
can't survive right but the the thing is
is I can't understand where this
blue-collar billionaire [__] came from
because the actual real blue collar
billionaire in our country is [__]
Warren Buffett that's the actual Blue
Collar millionaire I don't know if you
know that guy still lives in the same
[__] house he bought in like the 50s
he still goes to the drive-through
drives his own [__] car he carries
his own goddamn wallet and doesn't have
a computer on his desk he lives he lives
in Nebraska and that is the real blue
collar billionaire yes he lives in Omaha
but this some [__] has been able to
delude these [__] you call them Hicks
earlier these these delusional Hicks
into believing that he's a blue collar
billionaire and he can't even hold a
[__] shovel
come on man how did how did this how did
this get in this point Texas Paul
you know man I just there's they're like
weather veins Tony it's just anybody
that'll talk [__] to a liberal that's
their new thing man they've got no
values they've got no they are nothing
they are nothing they stand for nothing
therefore they are nothing
I mean rural folks
it's just as stupid as freaking can be
with these people you know that's why I
keep pointing out that uh all their CRT
and anti-woke talking points come out of
the Manhattan Institute at 42 Vanderbilt
Way one block off of Madison Avenue
right right that's where your talking
points come from
[__] the New York you know what now
thinking about it because Evelyn posted
this on Facebook she said New York hates
you and she's and clown clown clown
clown she's talking about New York
hating Donald Trump maybe Texas Paul
what I'm missing is that the enemy of my
enemy is my friend because New York
[__] hates Donald Trump they've hated
Donald Trump long before that
[__] ever came down to Golden
escalator and started uh calling brown
people bad and rapist and murderers and
wanting to build a wall and divide our
country they hated new arcaded him long
before that so maybe just maybe the
reason why these these dumb
mindless rednecks love this guy is
because the New York Elites hate him too
so maybe that's what it is maybe that's
where this blue collar billionaire [__]
came from but he's not a blue collar
billionaire he's never worked a day in
his [__] life he's never ran a
tractor never he didn't know Adam he
wouldn't know how to start a piece of
equipment if it if he had to save his
[__] life just like this shovel he
doesn't know how to run it I don't know
it's it's just me but um I think it's
[__] hilarious and I think it's worth
mocking him here on the show
um any last thoughts on the blue collar
billionaire [__] because I want to move
on to another dummy
you know man I all I'll say is that that
these people we have to really really
understand that these people will you
know it's like you're talking about with
them how can they like Donald Trump how
can they do this how can that these
people you know did you never ask the
question how the [__] did the people in
Germany go along with this [__] right
exactly
it's these people it's these people they
will [__] follow whoever they're told
to follow whoever they've got their
little click they've been brainwashing
to say we're the ours anybody that's
that's the leader of the ours that's our
guy
you know I mean anybody that attacks the
Democrats attacks the Liberals because
we've been told liberals bad we don't
know what the [__] liberal means right
but we've been told it's bad
it's not like there's a dictionary where
you can look up that word or something
speaking of that this is a perfect
transition to Kevin Sorbo this
mindless idiot talking about red States
and blue States here he tweeted this
today yesterday excuse me
he says if you if or excuse me if we
could split up the United States where
all Libs would have to be in blue States
and only conservatives in red States how
long would blue States last
you couldn't be dumber than a dog turd
when you're saying this he obviously has
no idea no idea that the actual tax base
and revenue base in this country comes
almost the majority
of the states are blue where the
majority of the tax the revenue comes
from how can't this [__] we've
been yelling and screaming this for
years how can't this guy get this
through his thick head and this goes
back to the old stupid thing of the
blue-collar billionaire he's he's a
Republican and blah blah blah the coast
Elites you couldn't get more Coastal
Elite than Kevin Sorbo
are you serious this guy this guy's a
Hollywood Elite has been for [__]
decades Texas Paul and he's trying to
tell us he's trying to tell us that we
should divide up the states this is this
whole National divorce thing but what do
you make of this this Coast Elite
telling people in the country if you're
a liberal you got to live in a blue
State and if you're a conservative you
got to live a conservative a Nazi you
got to live in a red state
let's try it
let's try it let's do it let's see
you know I I tell you man I I live in
the country now I live out in the
country so much that I've got to use
freaking cellular friend for my internet
you know what I mean I can't even get
a DSL here I can't I mean I'm In The
Sticks dude and I gotta tell you I've
lived in cities and I've lived out here
in the country
City's better
it just is the cities are better and
they're like well these cities are
freaking hell escapes and this that and
the other they're talking to they're not
talking to country people there aren't
enough country people to freaking talk
to I can't hit my neighbor's house with
a gunshot man I'm telling you there are
not enough people out here to freaking
talk to you they're talking to people
that live in the suburbs
and
suburbs in Texas you go into Dallas
Dallas is a blue City you go into
Houston Houston is a blue City you know
that's why they keep trying to [__] with
the voting in in Houston San Antonio all
the major cities you know if you took
all those people lifted them up took
them out of them State and made Texas
just a red State this state would shut
down in a week
you know I found it interesting I found
it interesting and and kind of the same
line you're talking about because we
watched a few weeks ago uh what happened
in Nashville when they expelled Justin
Jones and Justin Pearson uh they tried
and to expel Gloria Johnson but she's
white so they left her in
um and then we watched um representative
Jones and representative Pearsons get
back their seats and come to the floor
but I found it interesting that uh
Cameron Sexton the speaker of the house
there was exposed and he needs to be
continued to be exposed that he doesn't
actually live where he says he lives he
lives in Nashville
you know what a few days ago I was like
you know that's that's kind of funny I
wonder I wonder
I wonder how much houses cost in
Nashville because if you go look up
houses in Tennessee Tennessee Missouri
Kentucky Arkansas uh Louisiana these the
Oklahoma Kansas these are Iowa Nebraska
these are going to be some of the lowest
cost of livings in the entire country
that's one reason why I I still live in
Missouri it's one of the lowest cost of
livings I probably I bet that my house
payment for my four bedroom house is
damn is probably less than a one-bedroom
apartment in Los Angeles actually I I
know that for sure that it's less but
it's probably half as much for my house
payment for me to own a house as opposed
to living a rent a one-bedroom apartment
and here's where I'm going with this
so I found it curious about Nashville
because Tennessee
um there there's not much as far as
property value in Tennessee but yes yes
Texas Paul how much I don't know a three
bedroom two bath house is in Nashville
Tennessee just take a wild guess soft
top your head what do you think it'd be
nice neighborhood yeah sure
three what three what three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand no a
nice in a nice neighborhood we're
Cameron section would look try again try
again
well I I mean try again what do you
think
no you're talking about 1.5 million
dollars huh go go on Zillow and look up
and and I'm challenging the audience
here the reason why Cameron Sexton lives
in Nashville is because exactly what
Texas Paul is saying the property values
are higher there's more of a property
value base which means there's more tax
dollars which means there's more
services which means it's cleaner which
means there's more Recreation which
means there's more things to do which
means there it's a Better Health Care
System there's Better Community because
they have the higher property values now
I'm not saying that people should be
boxed out of the market in Nashville
because it's obvious tennesseans most
tennesseans the reason why most
tennesseans wouldn't even dream of
moving to Nashville is because they
couldn't [__] afford it
but I'm telling you the reason why is
because they have things in that City in
Nashville Nashville is the country music
capital of the world
I mean it's a huge huge economic Center
of Tennessee for tourism just for
country music Alone Kid Rock owns a
[__] bar where he serves queer beer
like Bud Light like it's going out of
style in Nashville Tennessee and I would
guess that he rents that building but if
he owns that building that building's
worth at least seven eight million bucks
at a bare minimum in Nashville Tennessee
so Texas Paul is Right Texas Paul is
right there is income disparity in this
country there's also wealth disparity in
Tennessee and it's shown in Cameron
Sexton is the [__] epitome of it
because the son of a [__] doesn't even
represent Nashville but I bet that
motherfucker's house wherever the hell
it is in Nashville I'll bet that son of
a [__] is at least worth a million or
two million dollars so [__] Cameron
Sexton sorry go ahead
no I agree with you 100 he doesn't want
to live in his Podunk District out out
in Tennessee you know out in the sticks
he wants to live in Nashville where his
kids can go to school can go to a nice
School
you know I mean it's he wants to be near
the hospitals he wants to be near
everything that that comes with living
in a city cities are better people
cities are better I'm going to tell you
and if we ever got into some serious
urban planning they would be like
freaking Valhalla I tell you you know
just getting all of the services in one
place makes them more manageable you
know this whole suburb idea I hate it I
hate it it's what's killing Flint you
know that's what's killing Jackson
Mississippi the other thing that I'll
and we talked about this on the show The
reason why Democrats and these cities
tend to be blue areas is because
reasonably reasonable people have to
have serious policy to be part of
government because they have a lot to
manage like they literally have to
manage [__] sewer systems and
drainage systems they have whole Boards
of people I mean these people have to be
smart [__] and they're elected
and appointed to These Bars boards just
to manage store warm water
and the rule areas they don't need to
manage storm they got ditches Texas Paul
but I'm I'm saying what I'm saying is is
that rural areas should have access to
these things just like the city they
should have access to libraries they
should actually have access to health
care they should access to hospitals and
the good schools and well-funded
well-funded Municipal Parts but but they
don't because they vote in Republicans
no
yes yes Texas Paul you should have
[__] internet moving stop well I
agree with that because remember you
should know you remember the old Rea
remember the old Rea program they taught
you about in school the rural electrical
Vision Association yeah why why
everybody out in the freaking country
has electricity right you know is the
the government said we've got to fit the
bill for this because companies won't do
it they should have done that with with
internet because I don't think the
people that stay living here need to I
agree with you they don't need to live
in freaking caves man they don't need
shitty services but stop moving to the
[__] country people
this is not what you think it is
that is true that is true the country
isn't what you think it is but but leave
the land for the people that produce
your food and live in a city because you
know it's really great when you're bored
to go to Dave and [__] Busters okay
there ain't no Dave and Buster's out
here guys Paul you're not advocating
that rule rural communities should lose
their hospitals or their schools or
their libraries they definitely should
use their people right yeah go move to
the city Texas Paul wants some some
Elbow Room out there
um I I gotta do one more thing we got
about five minutes left have you heard
this no labels oh my God uh here's have
you ever heard of Joe Lieberman
I've heard the name once before Jesus
Christ they're pulling Joe Lieberman out
of the stack to pimp this no late what
the [__] no one even knows who this guy
is you couldn't get more irrelevant than
Joe Lieberman Joe lieberman's Last Stand
was to [__] the country out of a public
option in the ACA that that [__]
piece of [__] he was the one that pulled
your public option and Obama took it
because it was what he could get at the
time because this idiot stood in the way
listen to how he's gonna stand in the
way now and he's going to make sure oh
that you have options he doesn't know
what options but he wants to make sure
you have him now listen I can tell you
from the inside that
um no labels is thinking about doing
this for all the reasons I just said to
try to get the government of Washington
working again but frankly uh the thought
that we're doing this so we're trying to
re-elect Trump is a exact opposite of
the motivation of everybody I have
talked to in No Labels who supports
exploring a third party ticket in other
words
um there's a dissatisfaction with Trump
and Biden but but uh almost everybody in
No Labels feels it would be bad for the
country if president Trump was uh
re-elected and I certainly feel that way
so to me
um uh Rick Wilson and then on the other
side Steve Bannon and others have
criticized us and said that we're really
in it to try to defeat Trump and elect
Biden uh and and all this is because we
threaten them
um because they're a part of the
two-party establishment which has
controlled our country now for too long
uh and uh we're threatening their
Stranglehold on our government and they
don't like it so they're throwing a lot
of mutterness but at us but I I don't
think the American people that I talk to
in small groups are larger by this
argument they're just uh I spoke to a
group a while ago and I said you know
we're not going to run this if we're
spoilers and if unintentionally we think
by our polling we're going to help elect
one or another the candidates and and
the response from the uh audience was
why do you worry about being spoilers
the current system is a failure and it's
hurting our country and it needs to be
spoiled oh well yeah that's that's
perfectly okay let's just let's just
tear down the entire democracy and then
give it to the fascists and let them
rebuild it back in their image let's do
that Joe Lieberman yeah what what
[__] idea this is not only is this
stupid they don't have a candidate Texas
Paul they don't they won't even name a
[__] candidate and the reason why is
because I believe there's not one
[__] that's brave enough to be
their candidate that's why I kind of
think this is a joke and it's flailing
at this moment in time because they
don't have someone that they can
nationally say well these are our
candidates now Tony this is very serious
actually they've actually only you know
they say well we don't want to be a
spoiler well then why did you only go
into states that
Joe Biden has to win to keep Trump from
becoming president I mean they are in
all the Battleground States and all of
their rhetoric benefits Trump
they are nothing but a get Trump elected
outfit the people that funded them the
the you know you've got the guy from
Lowe's CEO from Lowe's you've got
um just it's disgusting and Vicky no he
was a Democrat at one point Joe
Lieberman sold his freaking Soul what
Tony was talking about on his way out
the door he took a big freaking check
and we could have had a public option in
the Affordable Care Act there was a
public option there
here's his bio that they put up on the
screen here it says National co-chair No
laborers movement which that tell and
and I I hate to um you know [__] in your
cereal but Joe Lieberman being your
National co-chair No Labels kind of says
it all to me really a chairman of United
United against nuclear Iran great but
he's a former Connecticut Senator and
Vicki this is the most important thing
about him being a former senator of
Connecticut because he was a Democrat
from Connecticut but he was a money
grabber in Connecticut because if if no
one knows this the majority of the
health care companies in this country
um their headquarters are in
Connecticut and Connecticut and Joe
Lieberman was the one who pulled the
public option and the reason why the
health care industry did not want the
public option in the ACA is because it
would kill it would kill the the ability
for private insurance companies to
profit off of of people's bad health and
they knew that if they killed the public
option it would be a it would be a great
great money waterfall for them where
everyone had to buy health insurance if
there was no public option in this
country now am I disappointed that
Barack Obama took the ACA the deal that
Joe Lieberman did no I am not he moved
the country forward into a place where
we actually get health insurance because
the difference between what what was
before and what was and what is now with
the ACA is a health insurance company
can't sell you a pile of [__] dressed up
as a health insurance policy it has to
have certain things yes are we in a good
place for Health Care hell no no one
should no one should have to go in this
country because of a medical bill period
that is what we should be doing that is
what we should be focused on and that
and that is why we should elect people
who can actually get policy done show me
the No Label senators
because that's really how we that's how
we undermine this Texas Paul is we say
where's the No Label Senators where's
the No Label Congressman where's the No
Label Governors where where are they
what where where are the No Label
candidates so you only have a No Labels
candidate for president because it feels
like to me that's not a national party
Texas Paul it feels like to me you're
just trying to [__] with the
presidential race and you're you're
getting money from right-wing groups and
that's how we undermine this that's how
we push that's how we push the narrative
against this no labels things is we
question where their candidates are and
who their candidates are in every single
race where are your candidates in these
races where where's the No Label
Congressman they don't have them because
no one's going to run under this [__]
party of No Labels and independent
independent [__] independent [__]
campaigns with Joe Lieberman as their
national co-chair no one knows who the
[__] Joe Lieberman is nor do they give a
[__] I just have to keep bringing the
snow labels up thing Texas Paul and I
think we should keep banging on this
drum no and I didn't mean to somebody
put a comment out there that I meant the
founders of Home Depot no I didn't it's
Lowe's that's funding this No Labels
thing it really is Lowe's is funding
this [__] yeah I know we're used to
beating the [__] out of Home Depot
because the founder of Home Depot is a
freak but no actually Lowe's has gotten
into the Panera Bread has gotten into
funding this [__] and you know Ned
Lamont beat Joe Lieberman in a primary
and became the Democratic candidate
right Joe Lieberman ran as a [__]
spoiler against Ned Lamont right he
changed
he changed to be an independent yeah he
is all about spoiling races and now he's
sitting there trying to pretend like
he's not there to screw over the
Democratic party that's exactly what
he's there to do he's been a vengeful
spiteful little freaking Keebler Elf
since the day he got his ass whipped and
never got over it because they the
Democratic party said hey Ned Lamont
beat you there's nothing we can do about
it you lost he has been so butthurt
about that and has been trying to screw
us ever since
well I want to tell everyone because
um um I don't always agree with Rick
Wilson and I really don't always agree
or
um and I'm not exactly
um
completely enthusiastic about the
Lincoln project and excuse me if I'm not
but here's the thing and the reason why
is because of their their original
motivations but here's what I'll tell
you is that um because I I would like to
reach out to Rick Wilson so if you do me
a favor if you if you find Rick talking
about no labels on uh social media tell
them I'd I'd like to interview him I'd
like to talk to him about this I'd like
to bring him on the show
um and so if Rick gets this message Yes
Rick come on the show because
um as Joe Lieberman said Rick Wilson
um is is against no labels
um and he has the right right reasons to
be against No Labels be and the reason
why Rick Wilson is unique in this fight
is because Rick used to be the No Labels
kind of guy Texas fall he used to he
used to he used to try to run spoilers I
mean this is the Republican this is
always their [__] strategy it's not
don't have a policy don't have ideas
don't give a [__] what the constituents
say just try to spoil the race so you
can win that's it that's all we just
want to rig up and [__] make it to
where it's untenable for anyone else to
win but us and that's and and so I want
to invite Rick on and talk to him about
No Labels because I know he's against it
now Joe Lieberman says Steve bannon's
against it but the reason why Steve
bannon's against this because Steve
Bannon doesn't have control over it he
doesn't have fascist control over that's
why he hates it it ain't got nothing to
do with spoilers or not spoilers he
would love to spoil the race for Joe
Biden but he wants control and he wants
the credit it's the problem with Steve
Benny's a [__] narcissist
um so but Rick in his own right is too
but Rick hey man it'll be friendly I
promise I promise I won't challenge you
that much if you if you come on the show
uh everybody go visit
realtexaspaul.com go visit
realtexasball.com the link is down Down
Below in the description don't forget
that don't forget to like And subscribe
here at the Tony Michaels podcast on
YouTube I want to thank everyone out
there who's been going over to Twitch
watching on Twitch subscribing on Twitch
and following on Twitch because here's
the thing is if you want to give free
monetary support to the Tony Michaels
podcast it doesn't cost you a nickel if
you already have an Amazon Prime account
first off it's free to follow us over on
Twitch makes it really easy you just go
over to Twitch and you follow us but if
you want to give monetary support to the
Tony Michaels podcast and that cost you
a nickel what you do is you take your
Amazon Prime account and you link it to
your Twitch account
and you get one free subscription with
that Amazon Prime account and when you
do that and you link it and subscribe
every single month you got to do it
every month and you got to renew it
every single month we just had 18
minutes ago Shadow woman seven uh
resubbed for her for her no gifted
excuse me gifted a sub to someone else
so you can also gift a subscription to
someone else but go subscribe with your
one free Amazon Prime subscription over
on Twitch we get a couple bucks here's
how it works Texas Paul and you know you
know it's like these [__] so
Amazon owns twitch right
which is kind of you know deceiving here
but when you give your Prime account
subscription to the Tony Michaels
podcast twitch takes half that five
dollars and then they charge us a fee so
we end up getting like two dollars of
Amazon's money in the long run but it
doesn't cost the prime user a single
nickel so it is a great way if you don't
want to spend money but you want to
support the podcast with my with money
and you and you don't have extra or you
already have a Prime account it's a
great way so just go just go to the Tony
michaels.com you can go follow the
twitch
um that's free and then you can link
your Amazon Prime account again go go
visit realtexaspaul.com see all his
links there he's got a show on Sundays
that he does Texas Paul as always on
Tuesdays it's always a pleasure to have
you here my friend
um and any last thoughts that you get
you know man I just I really want people
to be aware we've we really have
a a real movement
from the from the ultra wealthy oligarch
class going on right now and I just need
you to be really keenly aware these
troll Farms didn't explode in Twitter
for no reason I mean they are really
funding this this very hard right now
best thing you can do block the trolls
make them rebuild their infrastructure
before the election
folks this is when we fight it this is
when we started I mean this is where you
lay your seeds in your garden let's do
this man let's do this get out there
support people volunteer this is when it
starts it's not don't wait till a month
before the election you know this is
when you have to be doing it now sorry
to go off on a table engage engage in
your democracy and engage now it's
important it's important in this moment
to be thinking about and have those
conversations and what you can do they
know what conversations you can have
come here every single weekday Newton
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch we broadcast two
hours every single weekday Monday
through Friday until tomorrow same time
same place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly Year we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon